foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy liberal World Order Friday
welcome to the cabal
ah
it would be nice if these [ __ ]
moglodytes would learn definitions to
words wouldn't it
oh liberal it's so scary now look it up
dumb [ __ ] just look up the word liberal
and would you please this is absolutely
it can you can't even believe
I can't believe it what am I saying I'm
not surprised you can believe this right
that it's Maga month
they declared July manga month
oh [ __ ]
I guess they're preparing for their
dictator their orange Mussolini Jesus
there's there's talk that he's gonna
announce that he's running for president
we're not even in the presidential cycle
and he's gonna announce that he's
running for president on the 4th July
that's what the Q anonas are saying I
guess
I I I don't know how the [ __ ] am I
supposed to know this [ __ ] how are you
supposed to keep up with these [ __ ]
whackados apparently he's going to
announce on the fourth of July that he's
running for president in 2024 even
though we're not even did the 2022
midterm if that is true if that really
happens which I don't think it will but
if it does happen
that only proves that he is absolutely
[ __ ] terrified terrified of what
happened
this week when Cassidy Hutchison dropped
bombs on these [ __ ]
absolutely terrified I mean someone
someone from the White House this
morning on CNN says the words liberal
World Order and they're like oh my God
the lizard people are coming out
go look up liberal first dummy
yeah you know what the [ __ ] words mean
if you Jesus you got the [ __ ] Google
machine right in your hand even go to
DuckDuckGo you can just go to DuckDuckGo
even you [ __ ] idiot and look it up or
dust off the the dictionary the Webster
open that [ __ ] up and start
reading maybe that's the problem maybe
that's the problem
I'm sure that's the problem
ooh bitching we see the uh the debate
for the Wyoming representative Liz
Cheney defending her seat in Wyoming
we're going to watch some Q Anon type
[ __ ] there
they invoke all kinds of nonsense and
all kinds of liberal world order stuff
you gotta go check out our thumbnail for
today's show as well and
liberal world order these [ __ ]
oh I just don't get it they don't
understand
what words mean that's why we're in the
situation that we're in
is they don't understand what words mean
they have no [ __ ] clue that's like
everyone trying to be Inspector Gadget
this is confusing the [ __ ] out of me
everyone trying to be Inspector Gadget
over the last few days on on [ __ ]
Twitter I'm out Grandpa Poopypants
losing his mind in the Beast of course
he did you don't need video evidence you
don't need to pick it apart you don't
need a CSI that [ __ ] you do not have to
CSI that [ __ ] here's how you know that
it's [ __ ] real is Donald Trump is
saying it's not true that is how you
know that it's [ __ ] real
and he's trying to convince other
megalodites his secret service to say as
much in public but not do it under oath
that's how you know it's [ __ ] true
you don't need any other [ __ ] proof
you don't need any other proof then he's
saying that it's not real it's [ __ ]
real
it's [ __ ] real of course it's real he
threw ketchup against the wall he's a
little [ __ ] he is a little [ __ ] baby
of course it's real
we don't need to watch video and CSI and
Inspector Gadget that [ __ ]
and what I don't know did people were
spreading around video of what they
thought and then the right wing was like
oh he can't from where he was sitting he
can't grab at the steering wheel and
then the best part was Maga was trying
to make the case that he's too fat to
actually get up to grab the wheel you
know they're they're a little Rambo cut
out of him
and all the conservative [ __ ] Nazi
rallies that they have you know they put
out the Rambo with his face superimposed
on Rambo as if he's some kind of badass
or something you know that's the image
they have them they print it on [ __ ]
black American they desecrate American
flags by printing that [ __ ] on there
they have [ __ ] t-shirts with this
nasty [ __ ] on it
but but when it comes down to that if
Donald Trump can lean from the the seat
behind the driver
to grab the steering like no he's way
too [ __ ] fat for that no [ __ ] way
could that guy lean forward to grab the
steering wheel he's too [ __ ] fat
one too many Big Macs I guess for Maga
oh my God
what have we come to what have we come
to it is it is uh July 1st
and so it kicks off the holiday weekend
of Fourth of July so happy happy
Independence Day not happy Freedom Day
because you definitely don't have as
much Freedom this Independence Day as
you did the last one for a lot of people
out there you do not have as much
freedom
this Independence Day that you had on
the last one
and and it's probably going to continue
that way if you don't get off your ass
and make sure the liberal World Order
wins
foreign
yesterday was a historic day
um the Supreme Court
swore in Justice
katanji Brown Jackson as the first black
woman to ever be on the Supreme Court
what historic moment
um as we have other history made by the
Supreme Court over the last few weeks
where they have stripped rights away
from katanji Brown Jackson
think about that for a second
what a historic moment the katanji brown
Jackson becomes Justice Brown Jackson
as the first black woman to ever be
seated
at the Supreme Court
and just days before that that same
Supreme Court Stripped Away rights and
freedoms away from Justice Brown Jackson
think about that for a second I mean
depending on which border which
imaginary line she's in
you know she's if she's in a certain
State she has bodily autonomy but she
drives across an imaginary line into a
fascist State well
she doesn't have quite the rights that
she had before she crossed that
imaginary line even though she's a
Supreme Court Justice think about that
for a second
I think a lot of people are missing that
katanji Brown Jackson Justice Brown
Jackson
is seated as the first black woman on
the Supreme Court she is what America
looks like
and just days before they Stripped Away
the rights of Justice Brown Jackson
before she was sworn in
absolutely
absolutely
Bonkers batshit crazy
I don't understand it
so on this on this Independence Day on
this July 4th
you have to remember that historic
moment
an historic moment that's that's the
bookmark in history
that we have for this Supreme Court
everyone wants to make it
about one thing or another but that's
what it is that's the Stark moment
that's what you should remember
so on this July 4th I hope you're safe
I hope I hope that you still have a love
for your country and a love for
democracy I know most of the viewers out
there are pro-democracy
and that you have a love for our
democracy
yes it's difficult it's hard it's not
perfect it has never been perfect as a
matter of fact
we have worked very hard and throughout
the decades
to make our liberal democracy small L
Maga don't freak the [ __ ] out Jesus
Christ calm down you know Jesus go
change your diaper small L liberal
democracy
our two-party system
the constitutional republic that we have
it has never been perfect never from the
very beginning it hasn't been perfect
and it probably won't be always perfect
for every single individual
but we must strive for equity and
equality and I believe that is the
signal
when a justice Brown Jackson is
confirmed to the Supreme Court of the
United States
now a lot of people want to point out
that oh well
that's that doesn't change the court
it doesn't change the court absolutely
it changed the court what are you
talking about
Justice Brown Jackson is 51 years old we
still have lifetime appointments to the
Supreme Court as of now
I mean if we elect the correct Senators
we can probably change that
but as of now we have lifetime
appointments what do you mean it doesn't
change the court it absolutely changes
the court
it gives us three women who look like
America
on the quote-unquote liberal
small L side
of of our democracy
that's important that is changing the
court folks
hope is something that we can hang on to
if we lose hope we are completely [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] if we lose hope
for our democracy hope for our children
our grandchildren the generations to
come
who will seek equality and Equity the
likes that we can never dream of
and the signal of that is the the moment
the moment
that our fascist bought and paid for
court takes away women's bodily autonomy
in this country
we seat a black woman the first black
woman on that Court
that's significant that's a signal
some people want to find despair in that
signal it's hope that's hope
Justice Brown Jackson is Our Hope
and she's only 51 with a lifetime
appointment that's a lot of [ __ ] hope
for a long [ __ ] time folks
so don't don't discount
the signal
speaking of women sending signals
we have the Wyoming representative
debate last night and yesterday we
watched Liz Cheney absolutely burned
down Donald Trump at the Ronald Reagan
Library
some are saying oh no one will ever go
back to the library ever again you
people are dumb
there were Republicans and conservatives
standing and cheering that Liz Cheney
finally said out loud what they're
waiting for someone to say
you cannot be both loyal to Donald Trump
and the Constitution
he is a fascist he is against the
Constitution he will tear our democracy
to the ground
so you thin bailed fascists out there
that want to call yourselves
conservatives who want to live in the
two-party system liberal constitutional
republic that we have in this democracy
you better pluck your head out of your
asses and realize that you cannot be
both loyal to Donald Trump and the
constitution of course we knew this all
the way back in 2016. the email lady
said it and she was correct you can't do
both it won't happen it won't work
eat Jesus Christ even lady G Lindsey
Graham said that back in 2016 if if the
Republican party places Donald Trump at
the head of the Republican Party it'll
tear itself apart and here they are all
this nonsense about Democrats are in
disarray get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] we are not in disarray that's
nonsense
we are all for Liberal world order that
is right we're all for Liberal World
Order
where Equity equality free free market
we can have tolerance of others ideas
Jesus Christ I want the fascists to vote
that's right I don't want to stop the
fascists from voting
you should have the right to vote in
this country no matter your ideals no
matter your skin color [ __ ] I even think
we should give non-citizens the right to
vote that's right I said it Jesus Christ
what's wrong with you Tony they're here
aren't they they're paying taxes aren't
they they can participate in the economy
they send their kids to school you
goddamn right they should they drive on
the [ __ ] roads
you goddamn right they should vote
it's not for this nonsense where we have
to we have to demonize people and
dehumanize people but Liz Cheney gets it
last night in the debate
my question is my question is do you
think Liz Cheney will win with the truth
in Wyoming
that's what I'm looking for
I'm looking for will Liz Cheney
win with the truth
will she
in Wyoming I think that's going to be a
big big signal
not just not just to trumpism not just
to Maga but also to us in the liberal
World Order well in the cabal
and these [ __ ] people
will she win with the truth
you talk about another signal
to this country involving a woman
uh Liz Cheney we know question another
woman Cassidy Hutchinson
this week and more big signals more uh
frightening frightening
Revelations
to the manga world that's why they're
still freaking out trying to figure out
oh did the fat [ __ ] attack the Secret
Service in the Beast no he he's too fat
he can't throw ketchup against the wall
he would never do that he's so great
come on get the [ __ ] out of here
everyone believes that [ __ ] here's the
thing about the the part the two-part
and I said this the other day the the
part about the ketchup
throw it into the wall and him getting
irate and acting like a little [ __ ]
child in the Beast because his mommy
wouldn't let him go to the place that he
wanted to go look the reason why that
[ __ ] is a true
is because it has nothing to do with the
crime everyone's like oh yes it does
because he wanted to go to the yeah but
him getting in a tussle and the Beast
regardless rather it happened or not has
nothing to do with the crime him
throwing ketchup against the wall on his
plate against the wall because he's he's
a [ __ ] sore loser and he's a little
[ __ ] had nothing to do with the crime
other than it shows his his [ __ ]
character which we already knew his
[ __ ] character we didn't need those
little stories to know his character the
point was was to put him on check is to
get him to ADM to admit that those
things were true and he's doing it he's
doing it he's like oh it's not true and
all his [ __ ] moglodytes Marjorie
Taylor green and the like are out there
saying it's not true he did not throw a
fit and he did not throw his plate
against the wall they're like yeah
goddamn right he tried to steal the
Democracy you goddamn right we want him
to be dictator but he didn't throw a fit
he didn't throw a fit because they
wouldn't let him
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
come on
of course he did that stuff that's why
he's saying he didn't he's focusing on
the ketchup and and the scuffle and the
Beast and of course the internet is
going again all CSI Inspector Gadget on
it I think it's nonsense who gives a
[ __ ] who cares what the video shows or
it doesn't show no one gives two shits
everyone believes that [ __ ]
that's the whole point of it that was
the point of the [ __ ] hearings
about putting the ketchup story and the
Beast story in the hearings
that was the point is to get America to
pay attention
is to get them to pay attention and
really to make him look like a fool
when he refudiates it because everyone
believes it
even the people who are saying that it's
not true they believe that [ __ ] that's
why they're defending it so vigorously
like if it's so if it's not that true
why are you paying attention to it that
much who gives a [ __ ]
it has nothing to do with the crime
that's committed that he's probably
going to be charged with if the truth is
that he's going to try to run for
president to protect himself from
getting indicted
about the evidence that has been laid at
their feet by Cassidy Hutchinson who by
the way
another lie that he doesn't know who she
is get the [ __ ] out of here he wanted to
take her to Mar-A-Lago with him when he
left the White House and the reason why
the reason why he wanted her to go to
Mar-A-Lago with him when he left the
white houses to keep an eye on her
because he knew exactly who the [ __ ] she
was and he knew exactly what she knew
he knew that she knew the [ __ ] that she
said why do you think he wanted to go to
Mar-A-Lago why do you think he wanted to
pay for her attorney
why do you think they made sure she had
a [ __ ] moglodyte attorney
and only up until a few weeks ago when
she switched attorneys to someone who
has a goddamn decent head on their
[ __ ] shoulders that realizes that hey
she may have some criminal liability
here she doesn't start squealing
telling the [ __ ] truth right out in
public under oath to make sure the
American people know she may be [ __ ]
because we all know Mark Meadows is
[ __ ] here we watched last night as the
news broke that Mark Meadows is the one
who was witnessed tampering
he sent he he had a messenger send the
message to Cassidy Hutchinson oh you
better be loyal or else oh that's a nice
that's a that's a nice life you got
there it would be a shame to something
happened to it
yeah we've discovered it was Mark
Meadows now I still am trying to figure
out who the actual messenger is the
third party messenger
I know they know who that is as well and
that person knows who they are
they would be not not surprising if some
of these people ended up
with cold cuffs around their hands over
this holiday weekend
oh how great would it be how great would
it be to rest these [ __ ]
at a rally on July 4th where Donald
Trump is is announcing that he's going
to run for president he's round them all
up oh my God you talk about fantasy boy
that'd make for a great reality TV I'm
just saying hey Trump if you want you
want to produce some reality TV there's
a [ __ ] there's there's some eyeballs
for you everyone will watch that [ __ ]
you won't you won't hardly get Americans
that won't watch that [ __ ] on 4th of
July watching all you [ __ ]
getting rounded up at a Nazi rally while
you're declaring that you're gonna run
for president 2024 is they've slapped
the cuffs on your dumbass
whoosh
but here we are here we are speaking of
July 4th the holiday weekend on Monday
we know it's the fourth of July and you
know we broadcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday on YouTube Twitter
and twitch and we simulcast from the
Midas touch Facebook page this Monday we
have a special episode for you me and
Gabe are going to take the day off but
that does not mean we are not going to
broadcast we have a special interview
with Dr Eric now that Gabe did a few
weeks ago we're going to put that
together for you guys to have an episode
on Monday so we will still have an
episode on Monday that is pre-recorded
we will Air it live for you guys to
watch and enjoy on the holiday weekend
and that's so thank you very much for
joining us thanks for being uh the the
greatest audience the greatest audience
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
the Midas touch Facebook page to all of
you out there thank you very much and I
hope you have a safe and happy holiday
celebrate with your family
but remember remember about
this holiday weekend this independence
day that we have less Freedom now than
we did a year ago and elections have
consequences
we are living with the consequence of
2016 folks
we are living with the consequence of
2016. that's what this is
hundo percento
and this holiday weekend is a reflection
of that so don't forget that
we must so Monday we are going to air a
special interview with Dr Eric we're
going to play a clip today Gabe has a a
little bit of a clip to put together for
you to give you a a preview of what that
interview will be again our episode on
Monday will be a little short but we
will have it there for you it will Air
live at noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific just as we air live every single
Monday through Friday
so I appreciate I appreciate you guys
um giving us the day off and uh
allowing us to give you content that's
pre-recorded
um but we will not stop we will not stop
yelling into the microphone no matter if
it's the holiday or not
matter what
uh so let's do this let's go to a break
really quick and then when we come back
hopefully Gabe Sanchez will join us and
then we will go to the clip uh the
preview and then and then guess what
we're gonna surf the Tweety tweets and
journey Trends there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on today
I got a lot of video I want to show you
a lot of video to get to so that you
guys can break down what's happened over
the last few days uh here in our great
liberal World Order
stick around we'll be right back right
after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
where back to the Tony Michaels podcast
geez I almost forgot it's Friday
I almost forgot holy moly you know what
Friday Friday phone end of the week
[Music]
and boy do we have a bonehead for you
we have a bonehead of the week for you
today could you know you know all the
new listeners out there we put out a a
poll every single Thursday bonehead of
the week you vote we break it down every
Friday now just go to our Twitter page
at Tony Michaels pod make sure to follow
us there now that poll is up every
Thursday
and make sure to subscribe to the
YouTube channel we put that thing on the
YouTube channel as well so you get to
vote not just on Twitter but also
on YouTube so don't forget to subscribe
here at the Tony Michaels podcast
also download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google every single
episode we even have best of the week on
Saturdays and bonehead of the week on
Sundays to download in and of itself
we publish seven days a week here at the
Tony Michael podcast
we do not let up
so thank you for joining us so we will
have we will we will go to a clip here
of uh Dr Eric an interview that Gabe did
with Dr Eric you know Gabe Sanchez our
our co-host
an executive producer here at the Tony
Michaels podcast he did an interview
with Dr Eric a couple weeks ago and
we're going to air it on Monday but
we're going to give you a little taste
of what that's going to be
um today in a small little clip that
Gabe has put together of that interview
so we will we will watch that and then
we will do a little bit of the [ __ ] list
Roundup because I do have some videos I
want to show
but then we'll go to bonehead of the
week
bonehead of the week who doesn't like
bonehead of the week
everyone loves the bonehead of the week
here
I mean I'm sure there's a few everyone's
like hey why don't you put in all of the
above buttons see the prom again we
tried to explain this several times and
all of the above are all of the above
option
that the problem would be that everyone
would vote that way and every week it
would be that all of the above would win
because these people really are the
worst boneheads in the [ __ ] world the
worst they're the worst boneheads in our
liberal World Order
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
liberal Ward or that's kind of funny
isn't it then let me let me show you a
uh a tweet here that I sent out this
morning of a graphic
uh I I just what I did was I just I just
went to
I I just went to Google and looked this
[ __ ] up okay it's not that hard here's
the definition of liberal right
on Google it's not that difficult to
look these [ __ ] words up it really
isn't
um it's an adjective and a noun if
you're gonna go with I'm a liberal if
you're if it's a noun a supporter of
policies that are socially Progressive
and promote social welfare oh my God how
dare you be a supporter
of policies that are socially
Progressive and promote social welfare
oh my God that word social is scary
[ __ ] boneheads number two uh the noun
is a supporter of a political and social
philosophy that promotes individual
rights are you listening out there you
[ __ ] fake treats
civil liberties democracy and free
enterprise
okay so you're either a [ __ ] liberal
or you're what a fascist
so if you're terrified of the
quote-unquote liberal World Order
that means you're [ __ ] terrified of
of a philosophy that promotes individual
rights civil liberties democracy and
free enterprise
yeah no [ __ ] Sherlock we realize that
that you guys are terrified this is the
thing people should not be scared of the
[ __ ] word liberal are being called
liberal it's really [ __ ] dumb
that we as liberals
pro-democracy supporters
actually you're scared of this this word
we should not be scared of the word
liberal or to be called liberal it's
really [ __ ] dumb
it's really [ __ ] stupid
you should embrace it you should like
you goddamn right I'm liberal yeah I
[ __ ] believe in democracy I believe
that people should have civil liberties
I believe that that
we should actually promote ideas
that may be different from my own and
I'm open to some new ideas even if those
new ideas go further than what I'm
willing to individually say we should
stay open to it
but but this the run away from the word
liberal is to run away from democracy
where do you think we got the 14th
Amendment what do you think that came
from
that was Republicans Liberal Republicans
they were radicals at the time is what
they called them they weren't
conservative
conservatives want to maintain the
status quo they don't want to progress
they would prefer not to extend civil
liberties into individual rights and
democracy through free enterprise
they want to conserve they want to keep
the status quo
or fascist even worse which I mean the
American American conservatism has
always been the thin veiled fascism
always
for years that's what led us to trumpism
Jesus Christ that's what the point was
about Liz Cheney this weekend and her
debate
and some of the [ __ ] she had to say like
the truth she had to stand on stage and
tell the truth
holy [ __ ]
it's frightening it's frightening when
Liz Janie is standing on stage being the
most liberal
it is frightening absolutely frightening
but that's the point
because liberals radicals and I'm
talking about Republicans
that's right without
Liberal Republicans are you listening to
me liberal Radical Republicans
Abraham Lincoln
would have not been successful in the
emancipation of slaves and the freeing
of slaves wouldn't have been impossible
for Liberal Republicans
because we used to have the political uh
landscape of federalist and
Anti-Federalists which we moved away
from that you can't even get these
moglodytes to look up and know what the
word liberal means forget about trying
to get them to [ __ ] understand what
Federalist and Anti-Federalist is holy
[ __ ] can you imagine
speaking of liberals great liberals
here's our co-host an executive producer
and uh Liberal Liberal World Order card
caring member uh I mean that's that's
what I do I I carry that card everywhere
I go I get a little bit of a discount
thanks to Soros oh great yeah yeah well
I I laminated my antifa is the antifa is
that card does that get you into the
liberal World Order is that uh yeah I
mean there's a couple there's a couple
passcodes that go with it but outside of
that you're uh you're pretty locked in
oh okay so if you got an antifa
membership card and do you have to
attend the weekly meetings where we
trade like um
cupcakes and stuff because you know I
try to attend the meetings every week
where we have like uh you know we bring
cookies and cake and you know we talk
about all these uh anti-fascist ideas
these terrible things like democracy and
several Liberties and individual rights
you know Freedom all those sorts of
things right well yeah it's horrifying
it's absolutely horrifying wait wait
wait wait wait wait hold on hold on hold
on I don't know if I made my payment to
Soros for this internet one second yeah
horrible your internet's horrible yeah
this is terrible oh my God I'm getting
an attack from all sides I'll be right
back yep okay good so apparently
apparently Gabe has lost his internet uh
connection because his Sorrows payment
did not come in he must not be he must
not be that dedicated to the liberal
World Order oh my God
I I can't even tell you how uh this is
frustrating as hell that we have to do
this type of stuff that we have to
explain what the word liberal
conservative fascist is to these people
and that that's why we're in the
situation that we're in is because they
just get to make up whatever the [ __ ]
they want and we allow them to do it
right we allow them to have this this
[ __ ]
weird place in our society where they
just get to make up whatever the [ __ ]
they want
and we're like oh look at those those
clowns over there so cute
no you don't get to make up [ __ ] we'll
call you out I've had several people in
the last few days we posted on the
podcast page
um at Tony Michael's pot we posted the
statement that Grandpa poopy pants gave
as soon as Cassidy Hutchinson swore in I
don't know her but I know her type [ __ ]
right just [ __ ] lies just even in
that statement you can see the [ __ ]
lies and then he's frightened we post
that everyone's like stop posting stop
posting him we have to ignore him like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
I'm not going to ignore the danger of
Donald Trump it's not gonna happen I
don't even care if they lock that
[ __ ] in a basement of a prison
somewhere I'm not going to ignore the
threat
of white nationalism white Christian
nationalism that he has [ __ ] stoked
in this country I'm not gonna do it I'm
not going to ignore it you will you will
lose your liberal democracy if you do
just like Gabe lost his internet let's
see if he's got it back here
oh my God
finally the Soros payment went through
it looks like it it took it it took a
minute I was very worried but uh we we
got through so thank you thank you for
everyone who is uh patient with me to
make sure that the order went through
right right the antifa internet is back
online apparently yeah well you know it
happens again again this liberal world
order stuff this morning when I saw this
I'm like this has to be our thumbnail oh
it has to be because because some people
are like oh my God I can't believe the
Democrats are talking or said this [ __ ]
like get the [ __ ] out of here you people
who are losing your minds because
Democrats say the word liberal World
Order yeah you're you're just as bad as
the [ __ ] moglodytes oh you don't
understand that liberal world oh my God
where where you won't go break broke
because of a medical bill where your
kids will start school at three instead
of five these are crazy saddled you
won't be saddled with college debt
you're your entire career what are you
talking about these are these are scary
[ __ ] things right these are very
radical things that nobody should really
have access to because again like even
if you look back at the decisions that
were made in them in the last week alone
right the last week and a half I mean
the fascist decisions exactly right like
yesterday you've got EPA you know last
week uh You've Got You know open carry
gun rights in New York which we will and
I think we have kind of seen the
beginning uh effects of that take place
we've got women's rights being taken
away in terms of Roe v Wade there's a
lot of things that are happening where
uh there's the Miranda rights in New
York there's all these things that
they're just like look up you as a
citizen don't really have these rights
you don't get to have Liberty here what
do you think this is yeah exactly it's
like the land of the free
right
hilarious right when you're taking away
people's rights but like I've you know
it is that it is that concept of like
owning the lips like we're gonna own the
lips like when they got sick with covid
and they're like I'm not taking the vax
to own the lips that's on you I guess
like
everything they do to own the lips and
all of these rights being taken by like
well you know what we're gonna take away
our rights so that your rights get taken
away just to own you [ __ ] and
it's like you do realize what you're
doing right now to own us like it okay
you know what fine it's all fine you
know what go for it let's see how it
plays out we'll just fix the [ __ ]
problem like we normally do
so you know I I know it's it's it's
Insanity that they don't and because
they don't understand words and they
don't understand the meanings like I I
embrace the term [ __ ] lib or or lib Dart
or whatever sure I'm liberal I got
called a lib turd the other day
yeah I am liberal I believe in democracy
I believe in civil liberty Liberties I
believe in individual rights I believe
in Freedom yes I am liberal if that's if
that go look up the [ __ ] word
yeah look up the [ __ ] word you're
either liberal or you're [ __ ] fascist
that's just at this point in this
country you are one of the other and it
has nothing to do with democrat or
republican or independent libertarian
whatever the [ __ ] it is
if you do not understand words you are
going to end up taking away like you
said Liberties away from yourself right
what the [ __ ] are you doing just I don't
know like you are liberal you are part
of this liberal democracy you are a
shit-lib dummy no matter what your views
are if you're if you're one of these
[ __ ] idiots that were bitching
because Burger King wouldn't serve you a
Whopper because you made the choice you
had the Liberty to choose not to get
vaccinated that was a choice you made
you're living with the consequences by
not getting a Whopper you still clearly
do not understand what Liberty is right
liberal is what conservative is what
freedom is you're just not grasping in
you are you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
this is the reason why we have such
trouble right now is because there's
such a small percentage but it's a large
number of people that are really [ __ ]
loud that are that just don't understand
that the [ __ ] that they have is afforded
to them through a liberal democracy
that's the lifestyle that you add is
afforded to you and you have that
lifestyle only because we are a liberal
democracy you [ __ ] idiot right it
really is fresh no I mean it's you know
it's like hey let's completely disregard
this document that you hold sacred
outside of the Bible that you read uh
which also is like you never read the
Constitution and or the Bill of Rights
that with it like all of these things
that you say oh these are our founding
fathers wishes right you you've got them
going to a point now where Lauren bobert
is saying the founding fathers didn't
didn't want this separation of church
and state when it's like they literally
they wrote it down they wrote it down
and in the First Amendment
it even covers this topic of church and
state right didn't she say it wasn't in
the Constitution right like okay if it's
you're talking literal like church and
state yes it's literally not in the
Constitution but what it is inferring or
rely or like uh uh
uh referring to
is actually the separation of churches
writing it's saying that the state does
not have the right to make people
believe in a certain religion that that
is you believe what you want to believe
but the government doesn't have the
overreaching power to say you have to do
this or you have to do that because of a
specific religion but that's why they
hate the Constitution Gabe that's why
they hate democracy that's why they hate
our system of government right because
it affords it affords people not to be
Christian nationalists right they
definitely want people to be Christian
nationalists that is the whole point
that is the point here man that's what
they want yeah they want the American
Taliban the Christian American Taliban
they want Christian nationalism they
want fascism it is it is Nazi 2.0 it's
the let's go Brandon Nazis it's Maga
it's it Maga is American fascism in a
trump hat that's what it is yeah and
we're living through it now and it's
it's it's difficult to understand
that a small portion of the country
believes in this stuff and a lot of a
lot of these uh Maga [ __ ] are
liberals they just don't know it then
they can't [ __ ] figure out how words
work and they just don't understand
exactly when they say these things they
talk about these things and again like
you know this is nothing new and this is
nothing that we're making up if you
literally have Lauren bobert video of
Lauren bobert on stage saying these
things and this isn't just the first
time either this is she said it a few
times now and this video has been going
around where she's claiming you know
what we need to get rid of that church
and state nonsense that's not what the
founding fathers wanted it's like well I
beg to differ considering the other
other like documents and other speeches
they gave where they specifically talk
about the separation of churches right
right they wrote it down dummy there's a
whole reason why they left
uh I don't know it's called England and
the rule
that the royal family had the the
monarchy had over
the the people they said you know what
no no no this thing is getting too too
confusing it's it these people are using
excuses to to how they should rule based
on religion and we want to get away from
that
and then you know there's a whole whole
history we even fought a war over it
right it was revolutionary it was crazy
right well you would think they would
understand but they'd understand you
would think they would uh get it get a
clue this weekend of course I told the
audience earlier
that is this Independence Day you should
uh celebrate our country but you should
understand that this Independence Day
you have less freedom than you did the
last Independence Day the other thing on
that too is I've been seeing online that
you know the right wing people
um [ __ ] nut jobs uh have been saying
that this month so we just had pride
month they're like oh man I'm so glad
pride month is over it's like okay
whatever uh then they go on and say this
is White History Month oh white so that
uh Tim Poole had uh deemed it Maga month
yeah they're calling it White History
Month oh okay one thing right right
which I wonder I wonder why Maga month
and white History Month are the same
month I wonder why they combine those
two seems kind of convenient yeah it's
just I wonder if it's going to be an
American Christian Taliban month I mean
maybe I guarantee that you know you
could name it that like I've you know
I'm already in my head thinking of a
video which is around July 4th and being
American history or White History Month
and be like okay I feel like every
[ __ ] month is White History Month
well I think I think we have um a
special
um in bonehead of the week we have a
special person for maga maga month so
we'll go over that but let's do this
let's go to the [ __ ] list Roundup I want
to round up the Tweety tweets into 20
transverse because we also have a clip
from the interview that we're going to
show on Monday uh everyone know that on
Monday we're gonna have a special
episode because it is the holiday
weekend we will Air a live episode
that's pre-recorded it's an interview
that that Gabe did by with Dr Eric but
we will we will show you a clip here in
just a minute after the shitless Roundup
so let's go to the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
about the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and now
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page Gabe I want to get right
into it I don't want to waste a lot of
time here is uh Marjorie hoof foot green
uh takes sends out this tweet says
Marjorie Taylor green is now blaming
Mitch McConnell along with Nancy Pelosi
for not securing the Capitol building on
January 6th green claims the pre-january
6 intelligence reports can be compared
to get this 911 uh level intelligence
reports listen to this video she seems
to be making the January 16th direction
is comparable to the Terrorist on 9 11
even so now she's throwing them under
the bus it's very confusing let's listen
we know that
um we know that there were serious
threats of violence we know those
intelligence reports were there oh so
now she's now she's admitting the truth
oh look at that she's like oh [ __ ]
people are getting [ __ ] arrested for
this stuff now
uh might want to try to clear my name
and it's like sorry Marjorie Taylor
green it's a little bit too late the
shit's already on the record and they
have the receipts so you trying to clear
it up now doesn't really help it
actually makes a little bit worse you
might as well just double down on it and
say yeah I [ __ ] tried to storm the
capital I told these people what to do
and that was part of the planning
involved you know but here's the thing
is that Marjorie Taylor green because
these people can't actually admit the
truth they stumble into it every once in
a while and it makes them look [ __ ]
dumb and here it's making her look
really dumb let's continue
the dumb [ __ ] here we know that Nancy
Pelosi knew about it and I'm really
bothered that Mitch McConnell probably
knew too and he ignored it as well it's
really weird it's really weird so she is
claiming that they knew about the
violence Nancy Pelosi and Mitch
McConnell knew about the violence knew
what would happen January 6. they knew
it they knew this was coming and they
did nothing so she's admitting plainly
yeah she's like was an Insurrection she
goes guys guys guys look we tried to
warn you what we were gonna do we posted
on parlor and we posted online and and
[ __ ] we tried to amplify it as much
as we could
as many violent people in Washington DC
that we possibly could that day what
didn't you understand it's just like
it's like an arsonist being like look
look guys I can't be all to blame for
the fire okay I told you when the fire
was gonna happen and I told you where I
was going to start the fire and I told
you what ingredients I would put
together to make the fire I told you how
much gasoline I was gonna bring to the
fire didn't you didn't you hear me and
it's all your fault that you didn't
listen let's let's listen to Captain
dumb Buck here we know that they ignored
these intelligence reports and these
intelligence the best were you could
compare them to 911 level intelligence
reports so in other words she's calling
the insurrectionist that she currently
wants to release because they're
political prisoners and they should not
be charged with anything she's comparing
them now in this clip here to 911 Terror
wrist it really is [ __ ] it's like
when they can't
um be Tethered to any kind of reality
this is what ends up happening this is
what ends up happening violence and and
possible uh who knows what else yeah
they ignored them they ignored the
president of the United States request
for the National Guard and these are the
people running our country right now the
reason why they they didn't give the
National Guard to the president United
States because they were scared he was
going to order and use the national
guard against Congress that's what they
were that's that's what they were
actually scared of because they saw that
Donald Trump may be trying to uh do uh I
don't know what is that word coup Christ
what the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
um speaking of wrong with people you
gotta want to just I just want to point
something out uh okay if anyone can
remember this maybe there's a clip or
something I I don't know if it actually
exists but remember that it might have
been just Facebook posts Marjorie Taylor
green is a in uh
uh and Ty Ty reminded me in the in the
comments here Marjorie Taylor green is a
911 truther right okay she said 911 it
was in and yeah in a video from 2018
Marjorie Taylor green falsely suggested
that 9 11 was a hoax so
I'm not exactly following what she's
saying here is she's saying that January
6th was a hoax too again if you are
trying to find logic in their [ __ ]
lies when they all of a sudden stumble
into the truth you're gonna be in a lot
of trouble because that's the trouble
with these [ __ ] is they stumble
into the truth every once in a while I
mean Jesus Christ you know the saying
goes a broken clock is right twice a day
right they stumble into the truth every
once in a while because they're trying
to make a point to to say it is
someone's fault January 6 is someone's
fault and we should blame it on uh Nancy
Pelosi and Mitch McConnell but by saying
that that it's someone's fault then they
have to admit that something went wrong
when in the same breath they're saying
well it was great it was a great day it
was a fantastic day for our country this
is really important I'm gonna I'm gonna
definitely make a FaceTime video with
Marjorie Taylor green now fantastic well
here talk about dumb [ __ ] and stupid
statements this is a little clip that
Republicans for accountability put
together of the Wyoming
um uh Congress debate for Liz Cheney you
see Liz Cheney in the middle there and
her four opponents um two on each side
of her listen to some of the Marjorie
Taylor hoof foot green type [ __ ] that
they're saying it's
it's alarming we're gonna go to what we
call a lighting round January 6. it was
a setup from the beginning we cannot
have uh actual
um
um
um oh gosh
um
what we saw happen on January 6th she's
like I've seen it all clearly an attempt
to delay the count of the electoral
votes coronavirus or vaccine policy this
should be great they knew I thought she
had Awards for his work in cytokines
yeah Mr faucini is one of the most
corrupt individuals in Washington DC we
are to oppose any vaccines everybody
ought to get vaccinated and we need to
do everything we can to protect
ourselves from future viruses
faith in the election process I
understand when I talked to Mike Lindell
he did say that there was a small small
course
that is alarming pimping the my pillows
on this thing fantastic Facebook yeah
Facebook yeah using the the system to to
steer people yeah uh we we know for a
fact all the major internets do that oh
1 000 mules movie is something that I
think we are real concerned about voting
machines that you know are suspected
fraud their politicians in this country
beginning with Donald Trump who have
lied to the American people he consists
well when you're standing next to these
[ __ ] weird I know Ukraine is corrupt
we've started it we got involved we
pushed them into we started it being
against uh the Russian government yeah
I think that's the biggest uh ticket for
the Ukraine's and the Biden
Administration with the front line and
the battle for freedom and I think we've
got to elect serious leaders serious
leaders
oh my god well that's the whole thing
like yes in comparison you're like look
I know Republicans are crazy but Liz
Cheney's like look I'm not that [ __ ]
crazy well well here you go here I want
to show I want to show her her leaving
remarks because again we've said it on
the show several times that Liz Cheney
is no friend to liberal or liberals or
rights or freedom and she's not she
voted against voting rights she is not
for women's bodily autonomy this is not
a friend she's not for uh children
starting school at five she's three
instead of five she's not four people
not going bankrupt over a medical bill
she's not in favor of people having not
to be saddled with an entire lifetime of
debt because they want to get a degree
so that they can advance their career in
this country she's not for those things
but she is for the truth in this moment
right right like and it's clear that Liz
Chaney is distinguishing herself with
the truth so she's having to be very
careful with her words but my question
was this morning will Liz Cheney win
with the truth but here is her here's
her closing statements at the debate
um which again make her look like she
believes in Liberal democracy and only
because folks only because she is trying
to run on the truth in Wyoming to set
herself apart from this panel of
wackadus
um that is running and to distinguish
yourself as someone who adheres to the
Constitution and the truth and she's
hoping that Wyoming will see that
through which I actually believe that
they will I think if you watch this
debate if you watch their statements I
think most people in Wyoming are going
to go yeah this is [ __ ] ridiculous
that you think she's some kind of
[ __ ] evil demonic Democrat just
because she loves the Constitution let's
listen right representative Cheney thank
you very much it's been a tremendous
honor the highest honor of my
professional life to represent the
people of Wyoming for the last five and
a half years I am a Conservative
Republican I'm going to work hard to
earn the vote of every wyomingite in
this election and I think it's important
for people to know that I believe that
the most conservative of conservative
principles is Fidelity to our
constitution so I want to point
something out here
um obviously she's talking about
conservative conserving the conservative
because she wants to reassure people
that hey I'm not going to I'm I'm I'm
not going to codify Roe v Wade right I'm
not I'm not I'm definitely not going to
extend a rights to people I'm definitely
not going to vote for voting rights I'm
definitely not going to do all that kind
of stuff that you would expect someone
who believes in democracy to vote for
I'm definitely going to do the opposite
of that but but this liberal democracy
allows for our party to exist in this
two-party system and I definitely want
to be the leader of that so what I'm
going to do is come to this debate with
coherent sentences yeah that's the
difference between her and all these
other people I was just gonna say the
whole time I've every clip you know that
I've heard her speak through so far in
these videos I was like yeah she's
pretty well spoken she's she's very
clear but in concise about what she
wants to say and she's also very calm
these other people are like uh it's up
what's the word I'm thinking of uh uh
liberal World Order uh you know like
it's when you're using people like Mike
Lindell or 2 000 mules or or whatever
other [ __ ] crazy fascist idea that
you're trying it's like people using
Facebook as a like oh yeah my source is
Facebook it's like you're trying to use
Wikipedia when you're writing your like
thesis paper right that's what I look at
like when we're in when we were in high
school our teachers would say you can't
use Wikipedia as a source you know like
you just can't cite it it doesn't it's
not something you can do and for the
same reason I would say
you can't use Facebook to go into a
debate and say well I saw this thing
about covid on Facebook and boy oh boy
Mike Lindell gave me a promo code for
the pillow and I slept great that night
and it's like what the [ __ ] right after
I right after I watched the [ __ ]
Movie 2000 mules right this is really
ridiculous myself it only gives me more
confidence that Wyoming will make a
great decision here just because she can
speak in coherent sentences like that's
that that's that at least she can do
that let's listen in Wyoming we ride for
the brand and our brand is the United
States Constitution so I'm going to ask
people for their vote I'm going to work
hard to earn that vote but people need
to know something about me I will never
put party above my duty to the country
which I will never put party above my
duty of the Constitution I swore an oath
under God and I will abide by that oath
I won't say something that I know is
wrong simply to earn those people to
earn political support that's what the
voters of Wyoming deserve that's what
the voters of Wyoming demand that's the
kind of respect that we owe the voters
of this great state we need to recognize
that if we are not faithful to the
Constitution if we Embrace lies if we
embrace the lies of Donald Trump if we
tell the people of Wyoming something
that is not true we will soon find
ourselves without the structure and the
basis and the framework of our
constitutional republic if we don't
abide by the Constitution when it is
politically inconvenient then we will
not have the Constitution as our Shield
here it is we send our first amendment
rights and our second Amendment rights
so I'm asking for your vote and I'm
asking you to understand that I will
never violate my oath of office and if
you're looking for somebody who will
this is great vote for somebody else on
this stage because I won't I will always
put my oath first if you're looking for
a criminal if you're looking for someone
who would commit federal crimes and
break their oath go to these people I
won't do it right I mean you know is it
admirable that that she's doing this and
saying these things absolutely
um is she using language that is going
to attract votes to her in Wyoming
absolutely this Cheney is no [ __ ]
dummy she's not stupid this is Darth
Vader Jr do not forget who she is and
that is very significant I believe it's
very significant that she is Darth Vader
Jr and we should we should make sure to
take
um them seriously uh when they when they
are being serious now speaking of cracks
with the truth I want to show one more
video before we go to your clip here
yeah this is is on CBS the uh this
morning
the governor of Arkansas Ash and Asha
Hutchinson says on there that he will
not support Donald Trump I believe this
is significant I believe this is the the
actual cracks and trumpism starting to
peel away from
um what the Republican Party The
Establishment how close they want to be
in bed with this thing I also see this
as a signal that they know that there's
going to be indictments
um and that their party is going to be
saddled with that their leader of their
party and members of their party who are
elected officials tried to overturn our
Constitution and tried to commit a coup
and take our democracy down and I
believe this is a small signal uh if not
just a little one it is a signal listen
I would not be supporting him for 2024.
he acted irresponsibly during that time
he was a risk to the nation absolutely
uh so that's uh that's my statement on
it I would not be supporting him and
that's all he has to say but folks that
is significant when you have a
republican now he's not up for
re-election uh but he is he is a
prominent National Republican it is
significant that he's saying this
um obviously I don't know I haven't
checked true social this morning but I
would imagine that Grandpa Poopypants
has already refudiated him and made him
into a liberal Rhino or some stupid [ __ ]
as part of the liberal world order or
some dumb [ __ ] everyone needs to
understand who Asha Hutchison is he is
no liberal he is no friend to Liberties
and rights and equality and equity for
all now he's far far from it but he
understands what the as at stake here if
they keep continuing to support this
fool and he understands that the country
is not going to put up with even
Republicans uh supporting such [ __ ]
so
um we have it I know did you check too
social is that what you're doing uh I
was I'm there right now he hasn't the
last name any man was 17 hours ago which
was a Breitbart article saying Trump
rails against Cassidy Hutchinson
testimony the woman is living in fantasy
land oh well uh and then it's the rest
of him you know he's like you know uh
oh there was earlier I saw that he did
make a typo and he said U.S stocks have
lost oh yeah yeah yeah yeah like Q Anon
has taken it and they're making it yeah
but he corrected and said U.S stocks oh
man which I don't know
if he reposted or if he just had someone
change it on the back end you know who
knows who knows one thing I do want to
do before um before we go to your clip
it's to wish Jordy myzealous a happy
birthday I think he's still trending he
was trending at number eight when I took
this screenshot so Jordy myzealous of
Midas Touch happy birthday Jordan happy
birthday happy happy birthday so if
anyone wants to go over into jordy's
page at Midas Jordy go wish him a happy
birthday today's his birthday uh Gabe
tell us about this uh clip of this
interview and then we'll watch the
interview or the clip of the interview
and then we'll go to bonehead of the
week uh so tell us about this clip
before yeah so uh I talked to uh Tony
was unavailable that day he was uh him
getting his getting his teeth checked
here we go so anyway I did an interview
give me the [ __ ] this is ridiculous I
did an interview with uh Dr Eric
feigolding
um he's an epidemiologist he is the
first person that sounded the alarm when
it came to covid-19
um you know the predictions that we have
you can follow him on Twitter
he has uh threads pretty much every day
where he breaks down kind of the the
situation that's still in effect which
is covid right and the variants that
happen
um very very smart guy very um very fun
person to talk to and he is uh he you
know I in the preview I asked him a
question about kind of like how we got
here but in the whole interview we go
over various things which is you know
the hitting one million deaths in
America
um going through kind of you know when
he realized this was a thing uh what we
can do to prevent it you know even for
people who are like I don't want to get
the vax or get the booster like what are
other things that you can do
um because again it's still a thing and
people are still getting sick and people
are right I've actually had some people
that I know who even have the vaccine
that have been tested positive and we've
seen some um prominent people even in
Washington DC that have tested positive
of course a lot of the vaccinated people
aren't as experiencing heavy you know
they say mild symptoms it's like I think
he talks about this yeah yeah I think he
talks about this and not this clip but
in the interview
um so take a look at this clip this will
be um we'll air the entire interview on
Monday it'll be our fourth of July
episode
um where we air it will be pre-recorded
but we will Air it live on Monday our
normal time noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific it'll be about an hour long so
our episode on Monday will be a little
short but we wanted to have an episode
and we thought this was a great
interview so take a look at the pandemic
there was very much this dunning-kruger
effect where take a look at this uh uh
if I can get it going here take a look
at this clip here and uh uh stick around
after this we will go to the bonehead of
the week
of course it's not what's going on at
the sound to a month new everything I
think during the pandemic there was very
much this dunning-kruger effect where
everyone was like within two weeks to a
month knew everything that they had to
know about covid right despite all the
years of schooling and experience in
times that you've actually been on the
front line studying viruses they said
I'm the real epidemiologist right I'm
the person who knows that
it's a hoax or it's made in a lab or
it's no worse than the flu right you
know but I'm curious like as an
epidemiologist as an actual
epidemiologist or someone who who knew
this was going to be a serious thing you
know how did we get to the state that
we're in right now yeah this is a very
good question obviously this is a very
long pandemic and disinfo misinfo had
played a very large part of it but also
political inaction political expediency
and um just sometimes downright ostrich
head in the sand approach to covid
hoping that it would just go away I
think obviously we know that disinfo and
misinfo is very powerful
um a lot of these messages very viral
they can go around the world three times
before the truth has the chance to get
its boots on and debunking is almost
never as effective as the original viral
Miss info and you know
hydroxychloroquine Ivermectin so much of
this has wasted a lot of time they're
not proven treatments The Proven
treatments have been drowned out by a
lot of this information
and you know the natural immunity oh
I've God gave me immune system for a
reason yeah well I remind people first
of all if they did not survive and a lot
of people didn't survive their first
wave
dead men tell no tales that they're not
here to say well no it's not enough only
those who were barely surviving and
recovered are able to even barely say
that so I think in many ways
people just heard from their social
networks that oh it's just like the flu
and you know let's be honest a lot of
January February March early articles
the mainstream news said oh it's just
the flu you don't need to wear a mask
that was incredibly dangerous so
obviously disinfo was very dangerous and
got people killed
um
but also just natural social network
effects of bad information
um and complacency and even the
mainstream media early on you know
played a role in you know basically
allaying people's fears and oh don't
worry about this but clearly they were
all wrong clearly this is really bad we
have had over a million confirmed deaths
recently and over a million excess
deaths in the U.S since February
um and worldwide anywhere from 15
million to over 20 million 15 million
being closer to who estimate uh and 20
million being The Economist estimate of
total deaths worldwide due to covid this
is this is not a lightweight pandemic
this is absolutely serious and people
have completely ignored that with a wide
variety of of excuses some from like oh
you died uh you know uh with covid
instead of friend covet whenever we know
that for the medical records most people
died from actually covid or the indirect
effects of covid
it's it's basically the short-term
complacency is very easy it's very
seductive it's very alluring to believe
that you know oh kids are immune and oh
you know 19 kids dying that big deal
whether it's gun violence or covet kids
are not supposed to die and all together
this is just a huge huge reflection of
our society how fractured it is how the
information is siled among those who
want to believe whatever they want to
believe in their little Network and
based on whatever their political
leaders or pundits promote
um and of course the vaccine misinfo is
is obviously the worst of all that the
red States that had the least
vaccination rates least boost rates have
way way more
um coveted hospitalizations and deaths
than the counties and states that have
the most vaccinations
and uh I think there's blood on the
hands of a lot of those who spread that
vaccine in simple there's blood on hands
for a lot of those who spread the uh
covet denialism covet minimization oh
covet is over message kids are
practically immune they have blood on
their hands
um and so many things have gone wrong
and even the CDC have
not been the best in you know
recognizing breakthrough infections how
even though breakthroughs rarely lead to
death breakthroughs can still trigger
outbreaks and complete new epidemic
clusters
um but of course unless it happened in
the U.S like for example the Providence
town Fourth of July Cape Cod outbreak
last last Fourth of July unless you know
it happened on U.S soil with U.S data oh
all the lessons of the Delta variant
um you know basically causing three to
four million deaths in India in the
spring of last year oh that doesn't
matter that's not real it's because it's
not here those far away that's India
right it could never happen here and of
course Delta van happened here and it
caused hundreds of thousands of deaths
in the summer and early fall
um you know I think complacency kills
right and and this pandemic has teaches
us that we should always be precautious
taking the precautionary approach saves
lives and actually saves the economy if
you act early you can actually save your
economy a way better than when all hell
breaks loose and people are
um you know entire Industries are
disrupted like Airlines even Delta
Airline who fought so hard to reduce
isolation and fought against Mass you
know they had to emit over a Memorial
Day weekend
um yeah we had a lot of cancellations
due to
a higher than expected covet absences
well no crap we've been warning about
that the same thing happened with
British Airways and easy jet at Heathrow
Airport just a month ago in April no
crap the same thing would happen in
America don't crap that if you minimize
it nor covet your own workers and you
know own um operations will be disrupted
because you know
people have such a short-term mindset
they want they want things to be back to
normal they don't see what's around the
corner they don't see the domino effect
of
[ __ ] hitting the fan and all hell
breaking loose later on
so there you have it you have um Dr Eric
with the interview with Gabe
um again I was I was at the dentist
office so I was not able
to to be part of to be part of the
interview but Gaby did a great job thank
you thank you with um uh Dr Eric there
and I think it's a it's about an hour
long isn't it I think is what Monday
like 50 to an hour long I have to go
back and look at it but yeah so Monday
so Monday we'll have um we'll have that
available for you again at our normal
time new Niche here in 11 Central 9
Pacific for Monday's episode it will um
be
um there for you guys to see and to uh
consume on Monday on July 4th actually I
um you recorded it a couple weeks ago
but yeah I was just gonna say something
about July 4th yeah I know I kind of
it's kind of it wasn't yeah it wasn't
until watching it again right now it was
like oh shoot he's hey you know that's a
nice thing about July 4th which you know
I I think it's uh you know he talks
about complacency and not just the
health of the nation but also the
academy is we should not get complacent
not just with covid but any kind of
disease
um because I think that's what this
misinformation stuff around the world
really puts us at risk not just from
covet but the next the next epidemic the
next pandemic that could happen because
these people have spread such a wide
disinformation about disease and how it
works and why we should protect
ourselves or why we shouldn't and I I
think um I think he spot on to not get
complacent not just with this particular
um um disease but others as well so yeah
I mean like I think it's you know
whether it's complacency or you know the
disinfo that he talked about oh boy
what's going on again there you go yeah
yeah it's crazy yeah the distance
filtered that that's that's the liberal
World Order filter I know that's like
hippie dippy filter right
um but yeah it's one of those things
that uh you know even our elected
officials you know marjor Taylor green
trying to push the idea that the
vaccines are whatever you know they're
cursed you've uh you've got Clarence
Thomas who's on bonehead of the week
this week which is another reason you
know him trying to push the idea that
coveted vaccines were made from aborted
babies like that's the person that is
deciding how to rule or judge on cases
that come forward that have debt like in
huge impacts on us as Citizens So
speaking of bonus of the week are we
ready with the uh the assets for
bonehead of the week for the boat and
everything do we have them okay
um once we switch over I'll load them in
okay so here here we go I I'm let's go
to a break let's go to a break and then
uh we'll go as after this break we'll be
right back with bonehead of the week
where you vote we break it down stay
tuned don't go anywhere right after this
is bonehead of the week stick around
we'll be right back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show as
promised in the second hour on Friday
every single Friday we go through
bonehead of the week where you vote for
the bonehead we break it down boy
and you guys not disappointed this week
[Music]
of the week so let's go to bonehead of
the week
holy moly let's see oh we gotta get it
set up here I mean we're we're falling
we're falling what is going on oh there
we go there we go there we go
what a week it was I mean the last few
weeks have been really bringing some
boneheads up to the surface you know
never discipline they never disappointed
Maga month Maga month should really
bring in some great boneheads we have a
special uh bonehead for Maga for Maga
month
um special a special a special Alpha
Geck for magma
[Music]
so let's get into bonehead of the week
here foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week where you vote
and we break it down you decide who is
the bonehead of the week go to our
Twitter page at Tony Michaels pod don't
forget to follow us there you can vote
there and don't forget to subscribe on
the YouTube channel hit that subscribe
button down below you can also vote on
YouTube and boy boy did y'all did
Charles vote this week emoted and um it
was it was
it was not a decision it was not closed
this week not close at all I mean you
know I was I I was expecting this
outcome but it was a bit of a blowout
I'll say that uh well let's let's look
at who we had on the list we had Justice
Clarence Thomas uh Mark Meadows and
Senator Mitch McConnell you know I'm I'm
already forgetting why the specific
reason why Mitch McConnell's on this I'm
sure it's because he's a [ __ ] it was
about the Roe v Wade and saying how like
uh if we codify row and the filibuster
then it would destroy you know well you
know you know that's right that's right
because President Biden said yesterday
that he would like to see the filibuster
carve out an exception to codify Roe v
Wade and Mitch McConnell's like this is
the most dangerous thing I've ever heard
can you imagine if we give back women
the rights that they've had for 50 years
this would be terrible like can you can
you imagine what it would do to the
country if we were to force in a stolen
Justice right it's almost like the guy
is tone deaf and intentionally unwilling
to you know he never wants to play fair
he'll never do anything that is for the
good of the people I mean he and Rand
Paul have abandoned their constituents
in their state they do nothing
unless it's for them right absolutely
well it's always this this selfish
fascist stuff but you know these these
these these three candidates kind of
like intertwine right like sometimes our
candidates they're just it's the
individualism of the bone-headedness
right but this week it all kind of melts
together here you have Mark Meadows on
the list with Justice Clarence Thomas
which Justice Clarence Thomas made the
decision about Roe v Wade and he went
even further to basically say we
shouldn't gay people shouldn't exist to
you know to the lowest common
denominator there but but we also have
Clarence Thomas and Mark Meadows
colliding in the boat world of boneheads
this week where Mark Meadows was on the
front stage of the criminality of the
Cheeto dust kangaroo goo and we know
that Clarence Thomas's wife Jeannie
Thomas was texting Mark Meadows yep
about the the Cheeto dust kangaroo cue
and trying to make Donald Trump the
dictator and the king and Justice
Clarence Thomas did not recuse himself
when making the decision of having that
evidence
given to the January 6 elect committee
so it's like this [ __ ] basket weave
of boneheads this way yeah man I don't
know it's a crazy you might you might
say it's a a basket of deplorables
that's good well you could say that
again there was an email lady that said
that one time she said maybe right about
almost if there was anyone who says
doubt me it's Hillary Clinton that's the
truth that's right I wonder that's if
that's why they were scared of her
emails and she had all that [ __ ] in her
emails and and they were probably all
subject had doubt me with the crystal
ball well as soon as there were the
emails they were talking about like
pizza and stuff like oh [ __ ] they
figured us out like that's what they're
like oh we gotta attack them all right
and that's why when after her and
podesta and everyone else about pizza
gate Pizza gate yeah they're the
basement of a pizza place that didn't
exist
um so let's I'll show you our bonus here
and Mark Meadows Mitch McConnell so I
don't know where where do we want to
start do we want to start with the [ __ ]
the Mitch or Mitch yeah [ __ ] McConnell
and I I think because it's pretty simple
to uh know why Mitch McConnell is a
[ __ ] bonehead but we'll start there
um really quick he still he looks like
he's still trending here on um on
Twitter I think I hope people drag him
yeah well and it looks like it's it's
his name misspelled wrong but uh he's a
[ __ ] yeah what it I I typed in [ __ ]
and this is what I get wow makes sense
but we know we know that uh leader
McConnell and maybe here's a good um
here's a good graphic even though it
doesn't have Mitch McConnell on it um
this has a lot to do with Mitch
McConnell here we know the three at the
bottom Gorsuch uh was seated because
Mitch McConnell stole a supreme court
seat from Barack Obama and we have uh
excuse me tearing my beer Brett
Kavanaugh the rapist here um Brett
Kavanaugh who we know he's bought and
paid for for the Supreme Court we want
to know who paid your debt Brad yeah and
then we have a handmaid's tale uh [ __ ]
over here
um Amy Cody Barrett I I I'm gonna call
her a [ __ ] I don't use that word often
but I think it's appropriate here where
she is one of the votes uh and Mitch
McConnell rammed her down our throat
because I really think that's where
Mitch McConnell's a bonehead here where
he's saying that that President Biden is
dangerous for pointing out pointing out
that that what they did with Roe v Wade
was take away rights from women and
Congress should act to give that right
back to them and codify that right into
legislation he's like whoa that's really
dangerous to question the fascist bought
and paid for institution that we made
sure existed to take away rights from
women to give women back those rights
that's dangerous [ __ ] guys we installed
it it's and they're like little [ __ ] no
no this is you know I mean like again
we've talked about this before which is
people within this party are going to
realize that when their rights get taken
away they're going to say oh [ __ ] I was
never really part of this party I was
just a political Pawn that people used
me to make a vote and to get someone in
office that they could then do something
like a point of Justice on the Supreme
Court to make laws that take away my
rights it's just like this [ __ ]
never-ending cycle where you're putting
someone in place who doesn't actually
care for you or has an ulterior motive
to some long-term goal like Jenny Thomas
using most likely her husband as some
sort of soapbox
and making sure that he votes certain
ways on laws once they got the the court
to be I mean it's not Supreme it's a
religious Court let's just call what it
is it is a religious Court it is not
Supreme it is inferior
but hopefully as time goes on
you know with uh with katanji brown
Jackson we've got someone with actually
some sense of clarity and Intelligence
on this on this bench that will
at least have her her name and her her
opinion uh on the record you know well
you know I said this morning uh having
to observe Fourth of July as
Independence Day realize the the actual
signal here where
um Justice Brown Jackson is sworn into
the court just days after that same
court takes away her rights think about
that think about that for just a second
that she is sworn to a court as the
first black woman on that Court which is
historic but historically the just days
before they actually took away rights of
her bodily at them right same course I
mean like you know it's it's one of
those things where it's like okay she's
married she has a daughter you know
she's you know in terms of you know her
bodily autonomy in terms of having a
child it's like all right fine you know
that doesn't really impact her in that
specific way obviously there's a much
larger thing that's at play here that
will but she also has a daughter that's
right who that I should
in their own home it's one of those
things where it's like
oh [ __ ] this is gonna like what's going
to affect how Judge Brown Jackson
directly right
um through her family and what that
means for her daughter and depending on
what imaginary line they've crossed it's
absolutely batshit crazy speaking of
batshit crazy
um our other bonehead nominee Mark
Meadows and we watched this week as the
surprise emergency
urgent hearing where Cassidy Hutchinson
um testified against Mark Meadows
basically was the entire thrust and
Donald Trump Donald Trump and Mark
Meadows have basically been welded at
the hip here for the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup for all intensive purposes
um you even tweeted out but this is I
think the reason why you wanted Mark
Meadows on the bow net of the week
because it seems like Mark Meadows has
really
um here's the slide that they showed of
witness tampering because that is
exactly what this is this is this is in
the moment at the live hearing that Liz
Cheney at the end put this slide up and
they redacted the name it just says a
person here it says let me know you have
your deposition or yeah let me know you
have your deposition tomorrow he wants
me to let you know that he's thinking
about you this is that friendship [ __ ]
this yeah loyalty you know you scratch
my back I scratch yours he knows your
loyal Cassidy is this person's texting
her and you're going to do the right
thing when you go into in for your
deposition now this apparently this
message was sent to Cassidy Hutchinson
um on March 7th is that right this is
the second time yeah yeah this is a
second yeah it wasn't wasn't the one
that was before because there are two
messages that were sent
um right they showed and this but that
one in particular but that one in
particular is when she still had the
Maga trumped-up lawyer right right
exactly so
um
yeah and probably at that point is when
she said nope okay
out it was discovered that the person
the a person that the the person who was
letting her know through this messenger
was revealed as Mark Meadows right um
now I don't know who the messenger is we
don't know who the messenger is the
select committee knows who the messenger
is right
they know for sure the messenger knows
that the select committee knows and I
wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if uh
those details are revealed because like
again you know they have a producer that
is that is setting all this up he's
helping them tell a story so that
everyone's like oh the boring C-SPAN uh
you know it's like oh this is this is
juicy gossip like what's going on here
right these people try to overthrow the
government but like wait wait you're
saying Meadows is Juicy come on don't
use Mark Meadows okay all right I'm not
trying to say he's juicy oh okay
his witness tampering that's juicy
exactly like you like not only did we go
through this whole thing and be like Oh
Trump was throwing ketchup on the wall
and having a tantrum and trying to grab
the wheel and choke out the secret
service agent you mean there's actual
crimes being committed then yeah yeah I
mean probably reason number one the main
reason why people like Margaret Taylor
green and all of a sudden saying that
this is like 9 11. and we tried to warn
them and they didn't listen we tried to
warn them that we were gonna we were
gonna try to go to the letters saying we
were gonna do it we put it online but
when I look at this stuff and I'm like
you know it is it is well done on the
production side uh much like our uh our
commentary streaming that we have for
the January 6 hearings right which is
done in partnership with Midas Touch and
the minus media networks so go go follow
the mind and stretch Channel and don't
forget to watch the July hearings by
word why why we're doing something yeah
yeah we might as well just plug it in
right but in this regard you've got this
producer who's saying all right this is
how we want to tell the story like these
are all crazy things we don't want to
tell it all at once we want to you know
spread it out and then after each
hearing or at the end of each hearing
they say
and the in the following the follow-up
hearing or the following hearings
whatever it might be you know you will
hear about this and that's what they did
here right so in the the one before this
or the two before that they threw out
all the names of the people that were
that uh that said no that they weren't
going to testify that they weren't going
to give a deposition so she's she's
calling them out and then in this most
recent one she was like oh just so you
know we ask everyone if they've been in
contact with Trump or any Trump
Associates and here are two examples of
that right here they dropped it as
Anonymous everyone's like oh shoot who
said it it's like the who shot Jr
situation right everyone's trying to
figure out who this a person is and who
these people that sent it were
and everyone's you know everyone's like
oh got to talk about it what happened in
the last episode you know of this show
what's gonna happen in next week's
episode and then they dropped a little
little spoiler a little tidbit and say
oh it's actually Mark Meadows from
someone else sending the message to
Cassidy Hutchinson about her deposition
and now I wouldn't be surprised if we
find out more details about the people
that were the the middlemen right the
people that were sending the messages on
behalf of Mark Meadows even though Mark
Meadows and his Camp have denied any
sort of wrongdoing so whether it's Rudy
Giuliani or whether it's uh stodgerone
or someone else you're talking about the
text message that we just that we just
right exactly who do you
get is because I have my theories
um but I'm not a uh particularly sure
exactly who it is
um I think I'm 60 40. I'm 60 on the Rudy
side because Rudy's dumb enough to do it
and I'm 40 on the stodger Rhone side
because he's uh he's got enough hubris
and he's cocky enough to do it thinking
there won't be any repercussions I
actually don't believe that it's either
one of those whoa I don't I do not
believe
um because I see where you're going I
think I think the thing is is that there
there are um coherent sentences in that
message
um they're not um two they're not too
overt they're a little smarter about the
language that they're using and it would
be someone who would actually you know
probably talk to Mark Meadows and I
doubt I doubt Rudy at that point
um would be talking to Mark Meadows or
stodger Roan be talking to Mark Meadows
I do in fact though bet that there is
one person that to this day is probably
still in in contact with Mark Meadows
and it's one of the people in this
picture if you notice here
one of the individuals in the green
dress is Cassidy Hutchinson the other is
Kaylee mcenany okay so and this is a
picture that was taken after the
election apparently while they were
going to Mar-A-Lago here's the thing
Donald Trump claims he does not know
Cassidy Hutchison and he claims she
knows nothing even Donald Trump Jr
posted on on two Central something about
she's a coffee girl or something yeah
yeah
why would Trump and the Trump team want
to make sure that the coffee girl was on
the Mar-A-Lago staff to keep her close
why would he want to do that I don't
know she makes good lattes yeah maybe
but my guess is my guess is that she was
kept close to Trump because they knew
she knew everything they knew she knew
everything and there's another person
besides Mark Meadows that knew that she
knew everything and it is one of the
people in this picture now I'm not
saying that it's I have any evidence
other than this photo right here
that they were chummy even after the
election meaning they were still
probably chummy up until last week with
text messages
um I'm just trying to figure out who
would be chumming with her who would be
able to write these coherent sentences
and not be
um be so avert to you know give the
mobster type language and I also am
trying to figure out who Mark Meadows
could convince to do this type of
witness tampering and I'm betting it's
someone who is smarter than you think
but not as smart as they yeah they are
so I'm not saying it's um Kaylee mcenany
but I am saying um it is Kaylee mcanin I
don't know
doubt me yeah get my crystal ball out
and so I I believe that it's someone uh
much smarter than than uh Rudy Giuliani
or staggerone for that matter so Mark
Meadows is another candidate but I want
to go to the dishonorable mention who
did we have that on the dishonorable
mention here Lou Dobbs yep why did we
have blue I think I think you had the
Tweet or the sorry the post that he made
on uh truth social oh a moment ago okay
well you know um Lou I didn't even know
he was still alive uh you know what I
fear about this
I mean I have I have that same kind of
gut reaction whenever I hear someone's
name and I go there's a lot
he's like uh another version of Donald
Trump like he's yeah because Donald
Trump has always wanted to be so many
people right like he longs to people
right he used to be the independent
voice on yeah you know he's a racist
he's a [ __ ] racist Lou Dobbs is a
racist and now he's full-on full-on oh
he loves Trump he loves to get on his
Cheeto Destiny right who dabs uh so Ron
post here fired Fox host Lou Dobbs and
we know he was fired from Fox News and I
think he has a show on some Traders
now uh weighs in with his rational
analysis of January 6th so here's the uh
here's the post on true social and that
Lou Dabbs posted the January 6th
committee is a vicious partisan panel of
the Marxist dem's most hateful ignorant
cretans who are without conscience only
the hopelessly stupid would believe a
word they utter here's the thing he's
calling them a panel of marxist stems
not
I I still can't figure this out
every person who's been part of the
administration are that the
administration tried to bully other than
the two election workers that they had
testified
um have been I don't know exactly what
political party you would call this
Republicans
Republicans Cassidy Hutchinson worked
for [ __ ] Ted Cruz and Steve scalise
yeah then she was put into the White
House and soon became the aid to Mark
Meadows who is the [ __ ] who invented
the freedom caucus inside the [ __ ]
house
now also she went to Mar-A-Lago after
the administration was what what
thankfully was axed after January 20th
when Joe Biden was sworn in
the person who actually deposed in
public the other day for the testimony
of a republican aide to a republican
chief of staff was a [ __ ] Republican
whose name is Liz Cheney whose father
was the vice president United States in
a republican Administration these are
not marxists these are not Democrats Lou
Dobbs has [ __ ] for brains and he
definitely is a [ __ ] bonehead I don't
know if you have anything to say but
that's all I know I'm gonna say that
this guy is uh he's whenever I see Lou
Dobbs he's kind of like uh mashed
potatoes put into a Saran Wrap like
that's what I feel like he reminds me of
and this guy has really gone from
somebody who well I mean he was a
[ __ ] the whole time but he's really
gone all the way to the right and
extreme to say like oh hey Trump you
know how do you like your balls tingled
and now you know he's trying to push
these what and what I would imagine he
knows I feel like he's smart enough to
know that this [ __ ] is all [ __ ] but
he's pushing this as an attempt to say
well there is a very very uh uh small
but but riled up group that support
Trump that will push my podcast numbers
for the Great America show and this is
good stuff this is great stuff to push
on Truth social and I don't know if he
actually believes it maybe he does after
long enough to hearing himself talk
but I do I do think that Lou Dobbs is an
idiot he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh in that
sense of like
being smart enough to know what the what
the like what this was he's always
integrated he's always denigrated
migrant workers he's always denigrated
brown people in this country
um and you know he he definitely hates
immigration this guy is a [ __ ] racist
he's always been a racist he will
continue to be a racist and he's a
[ __ ] liar he's a goddamn liar and
it's no more appropriate that he would
spew these lies over on Donald Trump's
fraudulent social media site with the
name true social right it really is
[ __ ] just batshit crazy that that is
the world that we live in it's [ __ ]
ridiculous absolutely ridiculous so [ __ ]
Lou dubs [ __ ] them
um let's go to the alpha guck of the
week because I I kind of chose because
you wanted to know who the uh DM and
Alpha cook was and I I recommended Lou
Dobbs and this guy can you tell us who
who this weirdo is because he does yeah
this you picked out you picked out one
of the weirdest [ __ ] pictures picked
out I believe the best photo that really
shows Tim pool now yes Tim pool uh you
might not notice who he is I don't think
he's been on the boat yeah I had to make
this photo this morning okay so if you
if you just take your finger and you
just cover his forehead and imagine it's
a beanie that would be Tim pool you know
Tim oh he's the guy that wears the black
beanie exactly now every you know from
his beginning uh advice you know he was
uh occupy New York like all of that
stuff that he was involved in and then
he has gone all the way you know to the
right you know far [ __ ] right where
he's been pushing ideas uh that are
racist the guys are racist well you know
he he's a fascist he he he's very much
uh you know he's Pro Kyle Rittenhouse
and all these other wannabe uh but don't
you think Tim pool's kind of like pre-jo
Rogan Joe Rogan don't you yeah I mean
like he's kind of if if Joe Rogan
because he claims like I used to be a
liberal but he never really [ __ ] was
right I mean it Tim Poole is like if Joe
Rogan didn't take steroids all right
that's what that's what Tim pool is Tim
Poole has a podcast wears a beanie he's
got he actually posted this picture by
the way he's got a he's got like an old
school uh like gun and a knife like he
would actually what do you mean like
like he's like if you look up if you
look no like on his in his podcast
Studio like if you look up an image of
Tim Poole online and you'll see in the
background he's got this like old like
revolutionary era revolver or gun you
know like you put [ __ ] a pellet in
and you know your your gunpowder and
then an actual sword right like you have
like a you know when the gun fails the
swords the next thing he's got him as a
cross on his wall nothing says Alpha
nothing says Alpha cuck more than a
sword and a gun and on a cross in your
wall Jesus Christ exactly the reason the
reason why I suggested him is the alpha
because here's why he he tweeted this
yesterday he said tomorrow starts Maga
month and I hope y'all are he tries to
be country but he's not are ready to
change your profile pics to American
flags I've got mine ready
so he's so part of Maga month apparently
is to um put the American flag behind
you because America nothing says nothing
says trade or more than posting the
American flag of a country you tried to
tried to overturn right he says I know
all the major corporations that benefit
from U.S tax law will want to celebrate
this country right I don't know what he
what is the [ __ ] does he mean by that I
don't even know like what does that have
to do with MOG a month I know all the
major corporations that benefit from U.S
tax law will want to celebrate this
country right what does that [ __ ] I
don't I don't understand there see
there's a lot of code talk right it's a
lot of code talk over on the right right
now because they're losing their minds
because really honestly they are afraid
that that that they're really D they're
Heroes here they're Maga heroes are
gonna start getting rounded up and not
only is the truth going to be told that
the January 6th select committee but
it's also going to be told in open court
in open federal court when these charge
charges and these indictments in these
trials start one of the first trials
we're going to see for seditious
conspiracy is scheduled for December for
the proud boys I'm sure it'll get pushed
because of Super Singing indictments
here that's my guess I think I think we
actually won't see a trial for seditious
conspiracy into the summer maybe even
the fall of next year right so we're
probably a year out from seeing a trial
of anyone uh yeah Cowboys Oath Keepers
Eastman uh Clark Meadows Trump himself
stodger Roan uh Steve Bannon I think
we're almost a year out from any kind of
trial that would happen for seditious
conspiracy
um so the but these people are really
starting to freak out because it really
is they're starting to feel that that
these the conspirators and overturning
our government are going to start to
feel the cold steel of the handcuffs on
their arms here soon
um well I think also because you know
yeah they they're very much kind of
worrying themselves we saw again you
know Margie Taylor green or Olivia and
like oh we tried to warn you you know
you guys didn't do it it's very much
like kind of like victim blaming in this
sense and I think these people are are
realizing that oh [ __ ] the January 6
committee that everyone laughed off as a
joke is actually coming to the table and
showing all of the [ __ ] they are showing
the video they're showing the
depositions they're showing the audio
they're showing the transcripts they're
showing the emails they're showing the
handwritten notes like they've got the
receipts and they're showing it and now
people within the party are like oh [ __ ]
um uh yeah so like we're not gonna we
don't want Trump anymore you know and I
think
they're very tardy or late approach to
dealing with Trump
is not going to save them it's still
going to cost them their position uh
their reputation whatever it might be
because they you know they double down
before to be like it wasn't an
Insurrection it was just a tourist visit
Trump didn't do anything wrong he didn't
incite anything and then now they're
like oh actually
he was very much involved in a lot of
this that now that we're finding out and
it's like oh [ __ ] whether they knew it
or not they're like oh now everything's
there's a spotlight on it and now we
have to be worried and I think that's
kind of what's Happening Here well let
me tell you there's something that uh
this this tweet here it says Maga month
begins he tweeted this this morning
number one uh Tim Poole got up early in
the morning uh in Maryland on the east
coast to 20 I mean that's that's 6 37
your time that's 537 right that's what
I'm saying he was I mean really early
Alpha Cook's got to wake up early dog
the other thing too here I think says
more about uh Temple than maybe anything
is he tweeted this from an Android phone
it really I mean yeah he would
definitely I'm not I'm not trying to
integrate any Android users out there
but I am apple is superior I mean I'm an
apple supremacist yeah Twitter Twitter
does uh they they will put your [ __ ] on
blast you know whether you know it or
not um and you know no offense to the
green bubbles you know but uh I prefer
the blue bubble messages
uh you know I can react tap back do all
the stuff in there right right you can't
really do that in Android we we are here
here at the Johnny Michaels podcast we
uh fortunately elitists we are Apple
elitist um but but here he says uh Maga
month begins so everyone
um because I'm gonna put that his tweet
sucks obviously here because his tweet
does suck but I'm also going to quote
tweet him here so you guys can go find
this I don't normally do this but I
figure I figured this would work uh make
sure to put your Cheeto dust knee pads
on him
okay I'm just I'm just saying make sure
you put your Cheeto dust knee pads on
Tim so I'm gonna I'm gonna quote tweet
this so you guys can go find it and
don't do don't do what the Maga monk
Patriots want you to do and go quote
tweet something very very very not paper
let Tim pull the fool yeah know your
thoughts I I don't know you know it's it
is it is Maga month so let him go know
what you think of manga month
Tim pool
um he did he did win our Alpha cook of
the week in bone end of the week so
thanks Timmy thanks I guess I don't know
uh so let's and then this is and and
somebody mentioned this in the chat and
this could be true I wouldn't you know I
wouldn't be surprised that July is you
know uh White History Month or mag a
month or whatever as a dig at Juneteenth
that just happened in June yeah I think
actually uh Patriot takes I'm and I I uh
it's I think I can find something on
that we we Alpha cuck actually to come
full circle here we you coined the
phrase here on bone net of the week
Alpha cook
um many many months ago and the reason
why was because of an alpha cook himself
not Ethan Schmidt
um and here is the video let's let's
play this oh God yeah talk about a a
temple wannabe type thing here
um of course he's on Tick Tock I don't
know how they still I don't know I can't
figure out how he can still post on Tick
Tock with some of this stuff I don't
know but here is here is uh uh the alpha
[ __ ] himself
um talking about White History Month and
how this maga maga month is turning out
for them let's listen
Ethan Schmidt president of the
anti-masters club this July
let me ask you
don't answer that you have any do you
have any kind of clue why he's an incel
it it's it real come on this guy look
he's he's not in well here
to be an incel you have to intentionally
right right right right so there's this
thing where it's like oh yeah in cells
and cells you know you're making a dig
at them but is it this intentional I
mean he's produced no not at all I don't
think so like I mean like it's a
distribution yeah I think it's just a
[ __ ] dick that nobody wants to be
around like he's probably got [ __ ]
his his mouth smells like ass it's
[ __ ] rank uh his mustache looks like
it's a worn down toothbrush bristles he
looks like he wants to be uh a pirate or
in a western of some sort but he didn't
quite make the casting call like this is
the guy but when we say in cell like
obviously it's a dig at them but the
other part of it is that it's
intentional and I don't think for these
[ __ ] that it's intentional I
think these guys actually try to get
laid actually try to go on dates
actually use dating apps and try to meet
someone and they cannot get a date they
cannot get laid they could not even if
they wanted to intentionally
let me give you the proof of why that is
true let's listen yes it is White
History Month this July you know we need
to take back our white culture we need
to let all the Savages know
all the Savages we need to let them know
who built this country it was the white
folks the white settlers the white
pilgrims we built this country we
settled this country you know all the
best okay I can't take it I can't take
it anymore because it's just a [ __ ]
none you can't even get halfway that guy
is a yeah that is where Alpha came from
yeah he is the reason that I whatever
you know and kind of randomly said Alpha
[ __ ] and that moment I mean after he got
[ __ ] owned by that teenager who was
asking for uh signatures but
um
Ethan Schmidt like there are there are
very few people in this world that are
like really really hate or like if I saw
them on the street I would you know
I won't say it anyway we'll just say it
we'll just leave it there we'll just
leave it there we'll just leave it there
you're saying you're saying you may or
may not be saying that he has a very
punchable face yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm saying like you know speaking of the
face would be enough speaking of faces
that uh could or could not be punchable
um we uh we get back to the the
boneheads of the week Justice Clarence
Thomas he is our winner of the bonehead
of the week
um for many many reasons here but what
was the reason why what was the main
reason why you wanted the Clarence on
the list here can you I just think that
he has done a excellent job of putting
his name for shittiest person with a lot
of power
uh in the last couple weeks whether it's
you know trying to even though they
didn't take the case
of you know religious freedom with
vaccines but he tried to say that you
know vaccines uh came from aborted
babies you know taking away the rights
of of women their their bodily autonomy
and then saying oh while we're at it we
might as well look at contraception or
same-sex marriage you know and this is
really going down the road of even even
infringing on his right to be in an
interracial marriage right like he
didn't he didn't say it but I guarantee
someone is gonna bring it up later and
they're gonna based on his language
exactly right and like you know whether
it's the gun rights the Miranda Rights
like these are all things that in the
last week and a half you know it's it's
like I said on Twitter I said it's not
just the Republican motto of uh of
whatever her dumb ass name that she lost
her her primary buy but it was it was
Guns babies Jesus right like that is
also the campaign slogan for the
Republican party as well as hey hey
climate go [ __ ] yourself but like those
are in the last week and a half they've
done so much destruction that we have
done so much progress for over the last
50 years they wiped the they wiped it
away in a week
and that's that's the that's the Supreme
Court that we have here it's not a
supreme it's inferior it is religious
it is Christian nationalism in and of
itself uh Rex Chapman posted Candace
Candace Taylor thank you someone in the
chat said Candace Taylor I couldn't
remember her name but she [ __ ] lost
her primary yeah that's in Georgia and
then she she was like oh it's rigged I
got it
got a vote oh my God you barely got a
vote so Rex Chapman boast uh this uh
clip of Clarence Thomas at his 1991
confirmation hearing where he quotes I
believe the Constitution protects the
right to privacy because that's the
heart of Roe v Wade when they made the
decision in Roe v Wade the heart of it
is the right to privacy of you and your
doctor making decisions about your body
your privacy
um and then Rex goes on to write
Clarence Thomas in 2022 abortion
decision the Constitution gives you no
right to privacy here is the clip from
1991 of Judge Clarence Thomas
talking about Roe v Wade and what he
would do and not do for a decision and
may he may or may not have perjured
himself here let's listen
I believe the Constitution protects the
right to privacy
and I have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
or to
predisposed to Rue one way or the other
on the issue of abortion which is a
difficult issue I'm not asking you so
there you have it Clarence Thomas said
that he would not
would not make a decision based on
abortion he would base it on the
constitution of people's right to
privacy the even more important than
just abortion he said he would not go
after a privacy related issue which
which may not be who you [ __ ] who you
love right exactly
well rather he changed his mind which I
believe is far-fetched that he changed
his mind or he just lied to get on the
Supreme Court yeah
you said you you say it's you know it's
like when you're going on a date with
someone you're trying to get into a
relationship you're you might you know
be your better self you might get in
better shape you might say things that
you know you wouldn't normally kind of
uh agree to you know and then once
you've been in that relationship long
enough and you've kind of show little
cracks along the way of lying and doing
this and doing that then you're like oh
yeah well this is just who I am guys I
said [ __ ] it and that's what they're
doing right now and and Jenny Thomas is
100 behind that I have a very difficult
time believing that any sort of
discussion happened at the dinner table
where she did not talk about January 6
she did not talk about making Trump
still in office not wanting to an anoint
Joe Biden
and Clarence Thomas like yeah yeah we'll
we'll get to it we'll get to it it's a
long game but we'll get to it
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] uh Clarence Thomas
our bonehead of the week let's give him
his do here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so there you have it folks the bone end
of the week Justice Clarence Thomas [ __ ]
em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em hard hard hard [ __ ]
the button paid for fascist Supreme
Court the Christian nationalists that
are taking away our rights [ __ ] them
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em uh again every single
week we have the bone of the week pole
go to at Tony Michaels pod on Twitter
follow us there for the bone of the week
poll every single week and don't forget
to subscribe right here on YouTube the D
Tony Michaels podcast where you can not
only vote for born in the week but you
can watch the bone end of the week
breakdown in the second hour every
single Friday because we broadcast every
single Friday bone in the week in the
second hour
and we also we also download this
episode every single Sunday so don't
miss bone end of the week every single
week on the Tony Michaels podcast stick
around we got some announcements right
after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa bone of the week what a great Bon
of the week thank you everyone for
participating in bone end of the week
we really appreciate your votes we
appreciate your he crushed it he did
Clarence Thomas Thomas I mean
deservingly so yeah he is the bonehead
of the decade possibly I don't know it's
really hard with these [ __ ] to figure
out who is the biggest of the boneheads
but maybe at the end of the year we'll
do some kind of like um bonehead of the
Year type stuff or something I mean we
did like we did the bonehead Madness
yeah everyone liked the opponent man
this may we do some kind of uh bone end
of the year type thing yeah yeah just
gotta make sure that Lincoln project
doesn't steal it [ __ ] those [ __ ] again
Monday is Fourth of July it is
Independence Day here in this country
and we are celebrating the Fourth of
July this year with less freedom than we
did last year yeah so make sure when
you're out there at these celebrations
that you're having these discussions
that you're talking to your family
members your friends the people around
you about this 2022 midterm it is so so
important that we save our democracy and
we can do it because it is our democracy
if we shall keep it that is that is the
thing so I want to tell everyone have a
great and safe holiday weekend don't get
discouraged I know it is
um kind of and people are talking about
wearing black I wear black almost every
day I know Gabe's wearing black today
people are talking about wearing black
on on Independence Day but um again just
celebrate our independence day because
we still do have a democracy and it's
because of you out there who are
pro-democracy that is the reason why we
have it and we continue to have it if
you continue to believe in our democracy
and you believe in rights and freedom
and liberty now just know that we should
observe that we have less Freedom this
Independence Day than we did the last
make sure to tune in on Monday we will
have a special episode it will Air live
it'll be the interview that Gabe had
with Dr Dr Eric about covet and some
other issues now don't forget to to make
sure to tune in on Monday they have the
same exact time noon Eastern 11 Central
9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page have a great holiday
weekend we will see you live on Tuesday
don't forget to tune in on Monday though
we will have the show until then Surf's
Up [ __ ] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon